believe it a chi vit this is my first
it's graced what this is my first it's
grace video with dark hair very cool
cool beans as the kids might say the
kids from 1999 no one says that anymore
my life is bad here's a fun story I went
to South by Southwest this past weekend
and I did it so good I had a great time
at South by Southwest I saw great people
I had fun events that I attended etc I
left my purse in the Austin Airport my
whole purse just left it didn't need it
just decided the floor needed it more
than I did
tomorrow today Monday I have to go get
all new credit cards and a brand new
license I am NOT your role model welcome
to stream-of-consciousness Monday's if
you have not realized that this is what
this is now we're here we're on the same
page what oh there's a shadow cuz I'm
using a microphone I'm trying to be a
professional and it always but Hooves me
but who've great word why don't I ever
cite that as one of my favorite words
but hoof the hoof it sounds like a sound
effect not a word
goose is rubbing her body against the
couch come on come say hi come here
your head is the same size as my head
but your body is a third of the size of
my body isn't that interesting you could
give no [ __ ] what are you guys up to hmm
what do you [ __ ] pervs doing what I'm
doing it this hair huh fight an emoji
for that I did this scratch-off I lost
HomeGoods did you just do it downward
dog as a dog that was cute I'm very very
weird I have a Monday challenge just to
make Monday's a little bit more
interesting if you work in an office or
if you just work in a space with other
humans I challenge you to go up to
another human and grasp their head like
you are a human claw machine and then
walk away say nothing
I'm already thinking about you doing it
ah you get oh do I look like I own spray
paint yes I don't know coming to our st.
Patrick's Day show in Boston lately oh I
see this is this is it love music right
what's up honey
oh yeah dude rock and roll